- [Voiceover] Oxford
Dictionaries just announced
their word of the year for 2015,
which is the crying laughing emoji.
Reporting that it makes up to 17% of all
emoji use in the United States.
I know what you're all thinking,
how is it not the eggplant?
OK, we're going to go talk to some people
about their emoji use
and see what they say.
What is the emoji you use most often?
- It's either the cry laughing emoji
or it's like the little sassy lady.
- [Voiceover] You mean the one behind you?
- Ya, what?
- It's this guy.
- Definitely the tongue
sticking out emoji, like the--
- The word of the year for 2015
is the crying laughing emoji
do you agree?
- No that's stupid it's
not a word, it's an emoji.
- How is an emoji a word?
- Are they words now?
Is that where we are with life?
- Maybe, a picture is worth
a thousand of them so--
- No (laughs).
- That is so cool!
That's fucking dope can you believe that?
- I use that all the time,
just for anything, both
positive and negative.
- I think that's the
perfect emoji to be like,
my life is so hard and I'm really stressed
but at the same time
I'm laughing about it.
- When you can communicate
like with your phone
and through like pictures and stuff,
it's pretty much created
like this like new language.
- I don't think emojis should be words,
I think that's a
dangerous road to go down.
'Cause soon we'll just
be not communicating.
We'll just be staring at each other.
- Is that the only emoji that got in?
- Mhm.
That's not like even top ten emoji.
Poop emoji should go in.
Little chicken emoji,
what about the ghost?
I think that people who are
using the crying laughing emoji
are using it in lieu of actual humor
and they are weak people.
- Damn.
- OK, OK, I have something to say to that.
Crying laughing emoji,
number one, top emoji.
Number one top emoji.
- Yes, proves my point, proves my point.
- Say I'm wrong, say I'm wrong.
- You're wrong.
- I'm right.
- It's here! It's here!
- [All] It's here!
- Get it.
- There, get it.
- I think they got it, get it.
- Ya you get it.
- It's here.